the inclusion of minority women in ice
hockey has been growing and for two
current stars and a legend of the game
their hockey journey started with family
and a supportive community i got
involved with hockey mainly for my dad
and his brother they played for team
canada ball hockey they decided to put
their kids in it they started with my
two brothers putting them in and put me
in dance but then decided later that i
was able to play hockey too because
girls can do that as well when i was
younger i was fortunate enough to have
an outdoor arena in my neighborhood
that's all we did as young kids was go
down to the outdoor arena and play my
dad grew up playing hockey in
scarborough ontario my dad's black my
mom's white and my dad really just had a
love for the game growing up and he
played ball hockey roller hockey
whatever it may be but he experienced
quite a bit of racism in the game and
that made him want to put his four kids
in it to prove people wrong so that's
how i got into playing hockey overcoming
racism and gender inequality angela
james emerged as the first superstar of
women's hockey and in 2010 she was
inducted into the hockey hall of fame
now an assistant coach with the toronto
six in the premier hockey federation
she's inspiring the next generation of
hockey superstars
growing up i always knew who angela
james was but i never realized how much
i needed her as a role model and to
actually be a physical figure in my life
since she was announced as the assistant
coach for the toronto six i remember
i literally cried when i found out she
was gonna be my assistant coach they
don't call her the wayne grexie of
women's hockey for no reason
being compared to wayne gretzky or being
called the wayne gretzky of women's
hockey is you know to me a very nice
honor it was given to me when i was in
college and it's
kind of stuck around now the next
generation of women hockey stars along
with their hall of fame coach are
looking to push the game forward and
make the ice more accessible and
inclusive for all i think having more
minorities is very important there's a
lot of in many age groups
starting from the professional league
all the way down to when kids are four
years old it's a sport for everyone no
matter your skin type whatever gender
you are minorities are not if they're
good
it would do great for the sport you know
the more people in the sport the better
anybody who's interested in hockey no
matter what race
no matter what sexual orientation should
be invited and it shouldn't really
matter of the color of your skin i want
to see more colorful faces in the arena
i love seeing my team walk into the
arena we are so diverse already here
with the toronto six and i mean it
brings me joy to get to interact with
other people in different cultures and
races and i mean i learn from them and i
think that we can all learn from each
other i think hockey is amazing and it
should be a community for all